Finding things like the max of a list or the min or the second largest or the second to last smallest,
they are all examples of what are called order statistics.
Statistics summaries of the values in a list that depend on the order that they are sorted.
This notion is generalizing min and max, so the min can be expressed as order statistic 1.
The second smallest element in the list is order statistic 2.
The median is order statistic like n/2 floor.
The second largest is order statistic n-1, and the max is order statistic n.
To give you a chance to play with this idea a little bit of order statistics,
I'd like you to write some Python code to find the second most popular name.
I'm going to give you the list of the most popular names
given to babies in the US born in 1995, it's a yob, for year of birth, 1995.txt
and if you take a look at the file, you should be able to download this and take a look at the format.
It's pretty simple, the name and the sex and essentially a measure of how popular the name is,
and what you want to find is the second most popular female name given in the US in 1995.
Once your program is completed, it should be able to output the name,
and I want you to just check off the name that your program returns.